y
[Aplausos]
hola
llevaba menos de una semana en el poder
manuel merino anunció este domingo su
dimisión irrevocable a la presidencia de
perú presentó mi renuncia irrevocable
del cargo de presidente de la república
la declaración fue recibida con aplausos
en las calles que no renunció el pueblo
lo saco
pero no gasto no puede presidente no me
representa nunca me represento anunció
su dimisión apenas minutos después de
que el congreso le exhortará renunciar y
tras varias jornadas de protestas
duramente reprimidas por la policía en
las que hubo dos muertos y casi un
centenar de heridos una casa mucho
tiempo debía venir
mucho hacia los jóvenes
y justamente porque nosotros ha
representado a esa patria que realmente
estaba dormida ahora estamos protestando
y no vamos a permitir que nuevos
corruptos bueno a gobernar
la actuación policial durante estas
protestas ha sido severamente
cuestionada por la onu y organizaciones
de derechos humanos como amnistía
internacional le costó también el poco
apoyo político que tenía ya que la
mayoría de sus ministros se renunciaron
y líderes de su propio partido político
le dieron la espalda al congreso deberá
ahora designar a un nuevo presidente que
pacific el país una mayoría del pleno
del congreso debe así elegir entre las
listas que presenten los partidos para
formar una nueva mesa directiva del
congreso el presidente de esta nueva
mesa asumiría automáticamente las
funciones de la presidencia de la
república hasta las elecciones
presidenciales de abril de 2021